hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast risk mitigation and
management to ensure virus safety of
biopharmaceuticals regulatory
perspectives and industry best practices
presented by dr. hazel arana we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning this webinar
is sponsored by Sartorius the Sartorius
bioprocess solutions division is a
leading international provider of
integrated solutions for the
biopharmaceutical industry with their
extensive portfolio of products
technologies and services they cover
wide areas of a biopharmaceutical
process chain ranging from fermentation
cell cultivation filtration and
purification to media storage and
transportation for more information
please go to ww Sartorius calm I'm
Christina jewel of froth routes and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A box to let us know that
you're having a problem now I'd like to
introduce dr. hazel arana dr. arana is a
biopharmaceutical industry professional
with over 30 years experience in the
industry academia and consulting she is
a well acknowledged expert in the area
of
virus and prey on clearance from
biopharmaceuticals she has provided
consulting services in the US Europe and
Asia she teaches courses on ensuring
virus safety of biologicals as well as
other topics including good clinical
practices GCT good manufacturing
practices GMP downstream processing
navigating the drug development cycle
and effective biomedical writing hazel
has a master's degree in virology PhD in
environmental microbiology and holds
regulatory affairs certification RAC for
both the US and European Union she has
to her credit to books over 45
publications and for book chapters her
past assignments have included positions
at catalent pharma solutions why is
vaccines Pfizer and Paul corporation
please join me in welcoming dr. hazel
arana I will now turn the presentation
over to her dr. raana thank you so much
for that introduction and thank you all
for calling in to today's webinar
entitled risk mitigation and management
to ensure our safety of
biopharmaceuticals we will discuss today
about the regulatory perspectives as
well as industry best practices this
slide is essentially an overview of our
agenda for today's webinar we will talk
about whether virus safety of
biopharmaceuticals is an attainable goal
then go on to regulatory approaches to
our safety discuss some of the virus
clearance technologies that are
currently being used talk about upstream
risk mitigation approaches and then
close with a few concluding comments is
by our safety of biopharmaceuticals an
attainable goal or is it nebulous what
are the issues that we have to address
when we address the safety of
biopharmaceuticals to start with why
ensure virus safe here biopharmaceutical
short answer is patient safety to ensure
patient safety we have to ensure that
the virus and that various absence of
virus keep in mind that absence of
evidence of virus is not evidence of
absence it is not possible to test for
all viruses some mammalian derived
products for example plasma-derived
products doing fact pose a risk or
flores transmission for example the HIV
and the hepatitis viruses keep in mind
that our blood safety profile has been
enhanced considerably since last two and
a half decades some cell lines for
example the chinese hamster ovary cell
line or the cho cell lines do contain
non-infectious and doggedness
retroviruses note however these are
non-infectious and therefore pose only a
theoretical risk of virus transmission
adventitia Noirs may also be introduced
through process additives and through
GMP breach additionally new and emerging
viruses can enter our process stream
primarily because of globalization when
we talk about globalization it does not
refer only to travel but also to issues
related to supply chain as end and raw
materials as well as trade and commerce
the next slide talks about the types of
biopharmaceuticals that require virus
fifty assessment essentially any product
that has been directly sourced from
human or animal derived systems must be
tested and the virus safety must be
documented it is intuitively obvious
that some materials as for example
plasma-derived products or co
relation factors which are directly
sourced from humans must be demonstrated
to be faith other types of materials
that are directly sourced from human or
animal derived systems include enzymes
enzyme concentrates growth factors also
the recombinant products that are
produced in continuous cell line lines
must be documented to have appropriate
water safety in addition to those
products that are directly sourced from
human and animal systems any product
that has had indirect exposure to human
animal drug components must also be
assessed for our safety this includes
for example supplementation of cell
lines with animal drive growth factors
reagents used for example in cell line
establishment as well as even antibodies
that I used during clonal selection more
recently we also see novel production
systems as for example avian cell lines
the next slide essentially covers the
kinds of sources of viruses during
biopharmaceutical manufacturing for
example bovine serum and bovine serum
albumin used to be extensively used
during biopharmaceutical manufacture
this poses a risk of viruses such as
bovine virus diarrhea virus vvvv porcine
sourced trypsin was in fact used in cell
line establishment other other other
areas for example that required to be
addressed include chinese hamster ovary
cells and as we mentioned earlier these
are endogenous retroviruses however they
are non-infectious and we therefore need
to incorporate adequate water safety
assessment
working with these cell lines
additionally viruses can also enter the
manufacturing stream advantageously as
for example Mouse my advice which has
been a documented contaminant in my
environment in bioreactors and also they
could potentially be cGMP brief breach
during manufacturing the next slide is
essentially an overview of some of the
virus and prion contamination incidents
viruses have been associated with plasma
derived products and also in the past we
have for example had concerns with with
vaccines being contaminated with for
example polio virus rabies virus yeah
rabies vaccine and yellow fever vaccine
note that in all these cases what as
contamination was not due to the
negligence on the part of the
manufacturer but because detection
methods were not sensitive enough to
detect the model contaminant the next
slide essentially addresses the question
are recombinant products safe short
answer yes there has been no reported
transmission of pathogenic infectious
virus to humans from a recombinant
product that said contamination can and
does occur the production systems could
be potentially contaminated one example
here is the rotavirus vaccine that was
shown to be contaminated by four sine
circle virus or PCV this virus was
traced back to the porcine trypsin that
was used in cell line establishment once
again I'd like to emphasize that the
contamination with PCV was not due to
the negligence
off the manufacturer but because of
virus detection methods were not
sensitive enough at that time
additionally there could be cases of
adventitious loris contamination either
off the bioreactor itself or
alternatively facility contamination
incidents what are the consequences of a
contamination event key is the fact that
it has the potential to impact patient
safety these these drugs are a necessity
for patients or drug shortages do in
fact impact the patient when there is a
contamination event other issues relate
to regulatory and legal implications as
well as financial losses and lost
opportunity costs in the next section we
go on to regulatory approach to our
safety and risk management the general
approach to RF EC of biologics is a
multi-pronged approach that includes
appropriate sourcing and testing of raw
materials and cell lines and adequate
risk assessment validation of multiple
orthogonal virus clearance technologies
and in process testing keep in mind that
it is impossible to claim absolute
absence of Juarez presence the best we
can do is use a pragmatic approach to
virus safety assessment this slide that
demonstrates the sources off versus
potential sources of viruses for example
it's important to control the starting
materials plasma-derived products are
extensively tested in addition there is
donor selection exclusion and so on keep
in mind that once again no no plasma
pool that has tested positive for any
virus would be included during the
manufacture of plasma derived products
how
ever once again if if there are low
levels of pathogenic virus they may
escape detection during the manufacture
of recombinant products and monoclonal
antibodies there is an extensive
multi-tiered approach that involves cell
bank establishment in other words
establishing the master cell bank and
working cell bank these cell banks are
extensively tested and are required are
an absolute requirement from a
regulatory standpoint in addition it is
important to control the manufacturing
process through control of additives for
example serum was a common supplement in
the past however the industry has moved
away from supplementation with serum
please keep in mind that that serum free
does not necessarily mean animal product
derived free edition additionally
purification region creations such as
monoclonal antibodies as well as
experience could also potentially be a
source of Rs contamination the next
slide talks about raw materials related
challenges and that there are multiple
challenges when sourcing raw materials
to start with any biopharmaceutical
operation involves a large number of
components these include both chemically
defined and complex materials derived
from either animals plant or bacterial
sources additionally when sourcing raw
materials there are a large number of
suppliers which again requires
considerable vendor oversight
traceability of raw materials is a
concern and as we mentioned earlier
currently the focus is on global
sourcing some countries have a very
stringent quality system in place other
countries less so there may also be
variability in raw
materials even would stringent quality
management practices in place as we said
there are testing related issues
contaminants are not a marginally
distributed therefore detection is based
on probability and low levels of virus
may go undetected in terms of materials
impact even though materials do in fact
meet specifications they may as some
materials may impact the final drug
product quality the next slide
essentially addresses our concerns with
virus detection methods essentially you
only find what you are looking for for
example even though PCR is a very
sensitive method it only detects
specific virus primers also with in fact
ility assays once again specific cell
lines are needed to detect viruses and
this may pose a concern additionally
sensitivity it of a phase is a concern
in terms of the limit of detection low
levels may go undetected especially when
you have large volumes of raw material
or products also even when testing is
conducted there are sample volume
limitations other issues to consider
when talking about virus detection
methods include false positives and
false negatives the next slide provides
you with an overview of risk evaluation
in terms of sourcing and production
consideration the factors to keep in
mind are the type of product the
production system as well as raw
materials for example in terms of the
type of product directly a mammalian
sourced products such as plasma drug
products obviously pose a higher risk of
contamination as compared with a
recombinant product or a monoclonal
antibody the kind of production system
used once again factors into the risk a
well-characterized
cell lines for example the chinese
hamster over your cho cell lines pose a
significantly lower risk as compared to
for example advanced therapy materials
ATM PS for example gene therapy products
transgenic systems if appropriately
control posed a low to medium risk
rahmat with regard to raw materials
animal-derived additives as we mentioned
pose a high risk whereas indirectly
animal-derived systems supplemented with
for example be for meeting abstract
could pose a low to medium risk in terms
of the regulatory approach to our safety
a holistic approach is recommended for
example risk management is based on a
triad approach that involves risk
minimization or prevention through
appropriate sourcing incorporation of
robust virus inactivation and removal
steps and this has to be documented
through process validation and testing
during production to ensure absence of
contaminating virus or in other words in
process testing what does this mean from
a practical standpoint one question that
frequently asked is how much law
clearance is needed for a regulatory
submission unfortunately there is no
absolute value log reduction factor
required is determined on a case-by-case
basis factors for consideration are risk
associated with the starting material
for example a mirror mirroring derived
cell line poses a lower risk as compared
with the human cell line similarly serum
freezer lower risk as compared to media
containing serum other considerations
are for example the product indication
and patient population a young child
with mild disease is a higher concern
as opposed to a terminally ill patient
dosage and frequency of administration
is another concern for example large
multiple doses are a higher concern as
compared with one time small doses one
example here is coagulation factors that
may have to be administered with higher
frequency as compared to a small wonton
dose this slide essentially provides you
with the regulatory requirements both
for marketing authorization applications
as well as for investigational medicinal
products the regulatory references are
at the bottom of the slide that the
point I would like to make on this slide
is essentially that with regard to the
validation with an entire panel of
viruses the entire panel is required at
phase three or when the marketing
authorization is submitted the entire
panel is not needed in the case of
investigational medicinal products a
more streamlined virus validation
approach is acceptable why conduct waris
clearance evaluation studies the
objectives are twofold one is to
evaluate the ability of the
manufacturing process to clear that is
in other words inactivate or remove
known virus contaminants in this case
for example we could think about viruses
such as HIV or hepatitis viruses with
plasma derived products and retroviruses
in the case of cell line-derived
products the additionally the objective
is also to estimate the robustness of
the manufacturing process to clear not
just known viruses but unknown viruses
as well we apply over here a model virus
concept which is the use of relevant and
specific
model viruses as well as non specific
model versus the next slide provides you
with an overview of a validation study
design I could spend an entire webinar
just discussing validation study design
but at this point just agree give you a
brief overview with regard to this the
way the study has to be designed and
conducted essentially determine your
clearance objectives based on risk
assessments for example in the case of
plasmid right products there is a higher
risk potential so there will be a higher
virus clearance requirement identify
critical parameters and set acceptance
criteria depending on the particular
unit operation the critical parameters
will vary and we will talk a little more
about it in some of the upcoming slides
accurate process modeling is essential
the test virus panel included must be
appropriate for example there is a
relatively standard panel for plasma
derived products as well as for
monoclonal antibodies and recombinant
products it is also essential to
determine the clearance mechanism
whether it is in activation or removal
this is a regulatory requirement some
steps may provide both inactivation and
removal in this case it is essential to
document what part of the clearance was
due to inactivation perhaps due to the
low pH buffer or removal perhaps due to
the chromatography column ensure the
product validated is representative of
process product in terms of composition
that is purity potency and yield this
would appear to be a no-brainer on the
other hand you will be surprised at the
fact that there are times when virus
clearance studies are scheduled that
contract testing labs
and for some reason the product that has
been shipped over to the contract lab
may not necessarily be representative it
is important to note that studies are
typically can are done with operating
parameters set at worst case conditions
so this gives you an example of the the
scale down models and the kinds of
parameters to address for both the from
when scaling down from production scale
to bench scale for example if we
consider virus removal filtration some
of the factors to consider are the
protein concentration which should be
worst case or the highest protein
concentration that you anticipate the
operating pressure throughputs flux
temperature whether the testing whether
the manufacturing is being done at room
temperature or in the coal for the most
part most manufacturing processes are
done at room temperature in addition pH
as well as ionic strength has to be
representative Israel the next slide
talks about the categories or viruses
that need to be included for virus
validation studies a relevant Juarez is
a known or suspected virus or a virus of
the same species as the contaminant
worse an example here in the case of
plasma derived products would be viruses
such as HIV or hepatitis A virus h a be
specific model viruses are also included
these viruses closely are closely
related to the known or suspected virus
and have similar physical and/or
chemical properties additionally to
document the robustness of the
manufacturing process nonspecific model
viruses are included the next slide
gives you an example of the kinds of
viruses that are included for phase 1
phase 3 sparking study as I refer to in
an earlier regulatory slide if it's a
phase 1 study a small virus such as a
part of a virus is included as well as a
large words such as either Zeno tropic
murine leukemia virus for recombinant
products or HIV for plasma derived
products parvovirus is considered worst
case because it's a small waters and
it's non envelope difficult to
inactivate using an inactivation methods
and also it's a relatively small virus
the next slide essentially gives you
specific characteristics of these
various viruses that are included in
virus validation studies the virus
validation studies are essentially
performed in two phases you have to
ensure that any inactivation or removal
of hours clearance that you see is not
associated with the matrix we therefore
perform cytotoxicity and virus or matrix
interference studies to determine
whether the product intermediate is
toxic to the indicator cells
alternatively does the product
intermediate contain substances that
would interfere with virus detection or
does the matrix of the product interfere
with the detection of ro nucleic acid by
pcr in terms of a virus clearance study
the test article is spiked with the
appropriate virus and exposed to the
unit operation be it virus removal
filtration or chromatography or low pH
fractions are then collected during the
unit operation and acid using either
infectivity assays or PCR this slide is
essentially a schematic demonstrate
documenting the kinds of controls that
you would need to include for example do
you include a control to determine that
there is no virus inactivation in the
sample matrix itself
and also controls to the document that
there is no where is an activation over
time we will now get a bit specific and
talk about the kinds of viruses that are
a virus clearance technologies that are
currently used in the industry before
discussing virus clearance methods I
thought it would be good to briefly look
at the specific properties of viruses
that are important to us from a virus
clearance standpoint note that this
classification is obviously an
oversimplification but in terms of RS
clearance methods we can classify
viruses based on size which are the laws
of our sins for example Hopi simple
explorers and pseudo rabies virus as
well as smaller viruses such as part of
our SB 19 mouse monitor virus porcine
parvo virus and hepatitis a virus
viruses can also be classified based on
the presence or absence of a virus
envelope and examples of our envelope
viruses are Zeno trophic murine leukemia
virus HIV hbb HCV cytomegalovirus and
influenza worse keep in mind that when
methods are you specifically targeting
the envelope Dwarfs it impacts the
surface envelope and the virus may not
be rendered non-infectious however the
right the virus is not able to replicate
examples of non envelope lorises are
powerful viruses these viruses in
general are highly resistant to
inactivate inactivation methods such as
heat as a treatment and so on in terms
of our virus clearance toolbox virus
clearance methods can be divided into
our sin activation methods such as
heated irradiation or virus removal
methods such as filtration
chromatography and precipitation that
was
densely used in the plasma industry note
that methods must be orthogonal in other
words they must have different met
mechanisms of action so multiple
orthogonal mechanisms must be
incorporated the next slide is
essentially an overview of steps used in
downstream processing virus clearance
unit operations may be part of routine
downstream processing for example the
protein a step as well as chromatography
steps alternatively they may be
specifically incorporated into the
manufacturing process to estimate the
virus clearance capability of the
downstream process the virus
inactivation or clearance is expressed
as log reduction value the next slide
essentially provides an overview of the
kinds of steps that are effective for
both or non envelope viruses as well as
envelope viruses note that steps such as
detergent inactivation and low pH
inactivation are only effective against
envelopes vs. a method such as virus
removal filtration is considered a
robust method because it acts based on
size in addition it's effective against
both non envelope as well as envelope
versus some crew bond chromatography
spects for example an ion exchange
chromatography is considered more robust
than some of the other strips such as
cation exchange chromatography and
hydrophobic interaction chromatography
note that these steps such as
chromatography and heat inactivation can
act both are non envelopes as well as
envelope to viruses however the
robustness of the step depends on
process conditions this slide is an
example of log reduction values obtained
in Juarez clear and study
so for it up for example several of the
steps that are routinely used in the
industry and for which loris clearance
could be claimed our steps such as
protein a treatment either a low pH or a
detergent inactivation step and an ion
exchange chromatography affinity
chromatography and virus filtration keep
in mind for example methods such as low
pH inactivation as well as virus removal
filtration that has a greater than or
equal to sign in front of the numerical
value indicates that no virus was
detected in the effluent aliquot
stansted not also with low pH
inactivation since mmv is a non envelope
Dwarfs low pH and activation was not
determined on the arm using mmv as the
test versus the total the cumulative log
reduction value for the entire process
has to be calculated in this particular
case greater than or equal to 19.5 eight
logs was obtained for zeno tropic murine
leukemia virus and greater than or equal
to 10.2 four logs was obtained with
mouse minut forest we will now get a
little bit specific and using virus
filtration as one of the examples go
into some details with regard to key
considerations when incorporating virus
removal filtration the current industry
standard is to use a 20 nanometer
nominal pore size filter because the
removal is primarily by size-exclusion
virus removal filtration is targeted
against a broad range of viruses in
other words it does not matter whether
the virus is on the loop torn on an
envelope removal is based on size
exclusion it's non-destructive unlike
some methods such as heat inactivation
we
could potentially impact the proteins
the therapeutic protein and also virus
removal filtration maintains the
biological activity of the process it's
a robust and efficient virus clearance
step and it scalable and validate able
regulators often recommend that virus
removal filtration be incorporated as
one of the steps during manufacture of
protein therapeutics filtration with
size exclusion based removal is the
predominant mechanism is a reliable and
robust method for waris clearance this
next slide essentially shows you the
cutoff of a 20 nanometer nominal pore
size filter and the sizes of some of the
both the therapeutic proteins as well as
the viruses the non envelope viruses are
in the yellow and the envelope lorises
are in the green note that barb Avars is
at the cut off off the 20 nanometer
juarez filter so it is essentially a
challenge to ensure that a removal of
power of ours is attained while at the
same time obtaining high product
recovery this slide essentially goes
into details about the Sartorius varsity
portfolio the virus are filters that can
be used for monoclonal antibodies and
recombinant products are essentially the
verse of H F or the virus art cpv the
membrane is a PS membrane depending on
the feed stream either the virus at H F
or the virus at CP we could be used the
virus at hf is a high-flux high-capacity
filter provides high performance and is
also also has high pressure resistance
the virus oxy Peavy is a dub
once again provides like the virus rhf
hi virus retention both provide more
than four logs reduction the virus at HC
is a double layer PS which is suitable
for hydrophobic proteins and was
developed primarily for the for the
plasma products industry again this
provides more than four log reduction of
robust virus clearance the virus odd HC
is also a low fouling membrane so it
does in fact provide high product
recovering the virus out max is a
pre-filter that is designed specifically
to protect the virus removal filter
that's for example the HF the cpv or
even the HC the the virus at max is a
triple-layer optimized polyamide filter
and anecdotal as well as field data that
are documents that if the varsity ax is
used as a pre-filter to any of the virus
removal filters that are incorporated
downstream more than four to ten times
throughput can in fact be obtained these
are virus on media filter is a risk
mitigation filter and we will talk a
little more about the virus on media
filter when we discussed risk mitigation
when considering water filtration what
are the issues that have to be addressed
the process the process solution
characteristics must be evaluated to
ensure that there is ideal throughput
through the virus removal filter in some
cases premature following a blockage
could potentially occur this could be
either due to process impurities such as
protein aggregates denatured protein
host cell protein and so on present
the process our stream or alternatively
it could be a result of the high
molecular weight or the hydrophobicity
of the of the protein note that when
considering virus removal filtration
there are more more considerations than
just flux and throughput this next slide
essentially shows you how incorporation
of an adsorption pre-filter such as the
virus odd max can in fact significantly
improve the throughput and the capacity
through the virus rcpd filter factors
that could potentially impact waris
retention performance of Flora's removal
filters keep in mind that we would like
to think that virus removal by
size-exclusion is based only on size
exclusion however this is not or aren't
istari this is not the only mechanism
that comes into play during virus
removal parameters known to cause small
virus break through our concerns such as
flux decay and throughput issues such as
process interruption and pressure
release as well as low and high pressure
haven't shown to to impact virus
retention other concerns relate to
protein concentration buffer composition
as well as Warspite purity during the
worst validation study I'd like to
emphasize on this slide that each brand
of 20 nanometer virus repented filter
has a specific log reduction value
versus for decay and a throughput
profile worst-case conditions are
different for different brands are the
next slide shows you some shows you data
related to users related to pressure
interruptions on the log reduction
you of the virus at H F and the virus at
CP v5 virus artlab modules were used
were tested in each case and multiple
fractions were collected the first
fraction was the first 15 milliliters
there was then a pressure pause for five
minutes and following that connect the
next fractions were collected a tattoo
bar operating pressure note that
consistently high virus retention was
obtained and any differences in in the
in the bar graphs are only a limitation
due to the detection method as indicated
at the bottom of the slide no virus was
detected in all aliquot tested or low
production values are greater than the
numerical value reported in the graph
the next slide shows the independence of
high and low operating pressure on the
log reduction value of our Assad H F and
C Peavy once again operating these
filters at point one bar point three one
bar and five bar had no impact on virus
removal once again I would like to
emphasize that no virus was detected in
the tested a loquats or log reduction
values are greater than the numerical
values reported we will now go on to the
next section that talks about risk
mitigation and upstream operations this
essentially is a schematic of us
reduction in bio processing downstream
virus clearance is an absolute
requirement it's a regulatory
requirement to ensure patient safety
upstream risk mitigation is not a
regulatory requirement however it does
make business sense these this slide
essentially summarizes some of the
contamination incidents that
ever code in the industry look however
that these contamination events occurred
either in the bioreactor or the facility
and did not impact patient safety in
terms of risk mitigation approaches
obviously the primary emphasis should be
on quality prevention through assessment
inspection and control of incoming raw
materials in addition process
intervention approaches have also been
used for example upstream barrier
technologies like gamma radiation high
temperature short time and a filtration
this slide is a general overview with
regard to the mitigation approaches used
in the industry I want to point out some
methods such as I temperature short time
and gamma radiation are physical methods
that could potentially impact the
quality of the cell culture media that
that goes into the bioreactor after more
recently filter manufacturers have
developed virus removal filters for
upstream virus removal note that the of
our circulation membranes are applicable
primarily to chemically define media
this next slide gives you an overview of
sartorius's war assad media filter which
is a PS membrane provide a high flux it
has no no growth on a no impact on cell
growth or product expression note
however this has to be determined by the
user in terms of retention in addition
to greater than 4 log reduction for
small non-enveloped viruses the virus
odd media filter also provides greater
than 70 production for mycoplasma rwanda
Mona's Demonata which is the
indicator organism for sterile
filtration as well as leptospira
leptospira was real has come to our
attention recently because of a
contamination event in one of the bio
manufacturing facilities this slide
provides you with throughput performance
with some commercially available cell
culture media several of these media are
currently being used in the industry
with regard to virus removal studies
growl Satori's has conducted testing
with two different types of media the
proto 5 as well as the safc excel CD
Choudhry note that consistently complete
clearance of the of the virus was
demonstrated to wrap to wrap up this
webinar I just like to conclude with a
few comments as we said it is impossible
to demonstrate absolute absence of
juarez presence regulatory and industry
groups recommend a pragmatic approach to
our safety that includes appropriate
sourcing validation of the downstream
process as well as in process testing
that's said water safety assurance will
continue to be a moving target due to
several challenges for example the
increasing complexity of our starting
materials and production McCarron
assistance known and unknown viruses do
have the potential to compromise
biopharmaceutical safety and as we
mentioned there has been increased
globalization which then impacts
introduction of new and emerging viruses
into susceptible populations that said
there has been nope no incident of ours
transmission to patients through
recombinant proteins or monoclonal
antibodies
this is the result of continued
vigilance through an integrated strategy
that includes incorporated a robust
quality management systems control of
entry of adventitious agents through
prevention and intervention approaches
incorporate addition of unit operations
that provide robust virus clearance and
in process testing and environmental
monitoring programs to some of what
we've just discussed in this webinar
this quote is very appropriate the
weakest link in the chain is also the
strongest it can break the chain thank
you very much for your attention thank
you dr. raana for that informative
presentation it is now time for Q&A if
you have a question you'd like to ask
dr. arana please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button we
will try to get to all of your questions
but if not we'll be sure to follow up
with you after the broadcast let's get
started our first question is dr. arana
do you always need a pre-filter upstream
of the virus filter short answer no
while the pre-filter is not a
requirement it will improve your process
economics the choice of the pre-filter
is important prefilters can remove
aggregates either through size exclusion
or alternatively to adsorption there are
currently features on the market for
example the virus up max that I recently
discussed in an earlier slide that
removes aggregates by a combination of
both the mechanisms dr. arana can I use
a downstream virus clearance membrane
for upstream filtration of media media
components yes absolutely however once
again during manager
during the in addition to the
performance of the theater you have to
keep in mind as well as being young the
about process economic so you can use
the boundary membrane such as the virus
at cpv or the virus at hf or any of the
other filters on the market but the cost
in general is usually about 10 to 20
times higher and your flux rates as well
will be much lower now although prion
are not exactly viruses how does the
pharma industry detect or clear prions
well and ions are a concern primarily
for the brass for the right product
industry whereas for the biotech
industry it is a theoretical concern
that said even with brians we use our
multi prong pronged approach to in terms
of risk assessment risk mitigation and
management for right now we do not have
any significant concerns especially with
biopharmaceutical products or
recombinant products and I would be glad
to address this question and greater
detail offline because I could perhaps
do an entire webinar just on these
issues dr. raana what is the accepted
virus load for products for some popular
products that you know of whatever
the question I didn't quite get that um
we have an audience member who is asking
what is the accepted virus load for
products for some popular products that
you know of oh okay well actually once
again this goes back to one of the
earlier slides which discusses the
amount of all forest clearance that you
need the important aspect is to ensure
that you determine the baseline water
flows in the case of plasma drug
products it is inclusive Lee obviously
they will not have any detectable is the
keyword detectable virus load for a
variety of reasons on the UH so with
plasma drug products it is an actual
concern with recombinant products the
cell lines such as the cho cell lines do
in fact have endogenous retroviruses
which are non-infectious so the
regulatory requirement is to determine
the baseline retrovirus load this is
very often done by a method such as
transmission electron microscopy tem
once again i emphasize that the baseline
load is non-infectious and the
regulatory and Industry expectation is
that once that baseline road is
determined you need to incorporate four
to six 12 safety factor into the process
okay let's see um I believe that is all
the time we have for today for our
questions if we did not get to your
questions we will be sure to follow you
up follow up with you after the
broadcast dr. arana do you have any
final comments for our audience yes when
I want to again just to emphasize be the
industry applied a very pragmatic
approach as i mentioned absence of
evidence is not evidence of actions
whether this was a virus safety
assurance will be a moving target so
we have to continuously vigilant and
incorporate multiple orthogonal methods
if there are any other specific
questions you can send it to either to
me or two or three two one of our local
subs aureus representatives I would be
very glad to answer them thank you thank
you again dr. arana and thank you for
Sartorius for making this presentation
possible I want to thank everyone for
joining us today I want to remind you
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through februari
2017 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and we
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye thank you